hmm
uh
i
i like to squeak
god
great
i'm trying to figure out how to do a
good custom microphone
so far with your
well it was down at the kelvin
yeah so you know if you go light on the
ceiling
looks good
looks great
let's keep it guys
much
um
so
right well done buddy we got this now
is that your camera in the way today
so
right
my
you
god
thank you
okay
okay
okay
so
so
[Music]
hey
uh
[Music]
yes
this is really not good
it'll be like 30 minutes
[Music]
no one listen to jason
uh
all right
do
where are we you tell me
okay
yes
yes
i'm so close
so easy
is
is
um
is
i don't know
that weird at first but it's even more
weird when there's not there's nothing
right you know you're here
it's a good way it's a good time to
experiment with changing how you present
the game
more cameras on the field more sound
more
yeah you never hear it right like just
that one
you're up to a bad start
one losing strength
you're fired
they're terrible
you do your job well and nobody notices
the phoenix supreme court justice
what are they gonna do for the person
just trying to maybe travel on
teams planes yeah
thank god
okay
they just got away
is that school
but you can go to is
all right
okay
okay
i don't know
oh like the one yesterday it was about
three feet higher
all right i'll be better
are those in your belly
i should have never told you oh it would
have come out
just wait for the weight fair isn't it
presidential candidate
i sent you his picture no i did
better be good he's moving in today
so
okay
is
so
hey
outside
so
hmm
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
today my administration reached a
historic agreement with pfizer
to produce and deliver 100 million doses
of their vaccine immediately following
its approval
hopefully the approval process will go
very quickly
and we think we have a winner there we
also think we have other companies right
behind that are
doing very well in the vaccines long
ahead of schedule
as part of operation warp speed this
agreement will also ensure that we
receive an additional 500 million doses
shortly thereafter this is another
crucial step in our effort to develop
manufacture and distribute a vaccine
in record-breaking time really a very
small fraction of the time
based on previous schedules i want to
thank the fda i want to thank everybody
involved it's been an incredible process
as discussed yesterday the china virus
poses the greatest threat
to our senior citizens as we all know
the median age for those who die from
the virus is 78 years old and nearly
half of the deaths have occurred among
those living in nursing homes or
long-term care
facilities that's really something in
other words approximately
half of the fatalities have occurred
among
less than one percent of the u.s
population so think of that less than
one percent
half of the fatalities
so we know what to look for from the
beginning we have made it our top
priority to shelter
our seniors in early march we announced
guidelines suspending all
medically unnecessary visits to nursing
homes
and prioritized resources for
those facilities and we gave it a very
strong priority
fema has sent shipments to many
different locations of protective
equipment
and it's going directly to 15
400 medicaid and medicare certified
nursing homes
throughout the country today i'd like to
provide an update on the additional
actions we've
been able to take and they've been very
constructive first we're requiring
increased testing of the nursing home
personnel in states
where you had the worst outbreaks all
personnel will be tested at the highest
level
we're distributing 15 000 rapid
point-of-care diagnostic devices to
support
this effort these are the tests where it
takes five minutes to 15 minutes they're
very accurate they're very good
and we're sending them all over the
country and over 600 devices will be
also
shipped this week to additional
facilities
second hhs will be distributing an
additional five billion dollars from the
provider relief fund to all nursing
homes nursing homes and higher risk
areas will be receiving
more funding this money can be used to
address critical needs including the
hiring of additional staff increasing
testing and providing
technology support so residents can
connect their families and
they can connect to their families they
are having
a tremendous time they want to be with
their loved ones they can't do it so
what we're doing is we're
working it so that we can connect have
them connect with their families
if they're not able to visit third we've
been identifying especially high-risk
nursing homes and sharing that
information with the
governors so that the governors and
their staffs can take
appropriate action we're able to find
because of the testing programs and
other means we're able to find certain
areas at a very high risk the governors
can then take action
additionally cms cdc and the u.s public
health service
are providing enhanced technical
assistance and support
including visits to the highest risk
nursing homes
and that's their priority right now
nursing homes but the highest
risk nursing homes cms and cdc are
implementing a national training program
focused on infection control
for those nursing homes that need it
most
and we have them surveyed and we have
them mostly pinpointed
over the past few months we've created a
surveillance system to detect
outbreaks and currently 99 of all
nursing homes
are reporting directly to it so we have
great data
when a nursing home has three or more
cases we alert the state and make sure
that it responds very quickly we check
on it make sure
they respond very quickly i want to send
a message of support and hope to every
senior citizen
who has been dealing with the struggle
of isolation in what should be
the golden years of your life we will
get to the other end of that tunnel very
quickly we hope
the light is starting to shine we will
get there very quickly
but we send our love we send a message
of love
very important we're with you all the
way as far as the outbreak
in the sun belt i said yesterday we
continue to
vigorously combat the rise of cases in
the
south and southwest and the west we're
closely monitoring and aggressively
acting to control the infection in texas
arizona california florida arizona is
starting to come down
done a very good job they're all doing a
good job they're very talented people
there are likely a number of causes for
the spike in infections
cases started to rise among young
americans shortly after demonstrations
which you know very well about
which presumably triggered a broader
relaxation
of mitigation efforts nationwide and a
substantial increase in travel
also was a cause increased gathering on
holidays such as memorial day as well as
young people
closely congregating at bars and
probably other places uh maybe beaches
four or five different listed places we
have 12 that are listed on the guide
likely also contributed we're also
sharing a 2 000 mile border with mexico
as we know very well and uses a surging
in mexico
unfortunately it's with the president
and
it's a big problem for mexico but cases
are surging very sharply and
all across the rest of the western
hemisphere
257 miles of newly constructed wall
along the southern border has
had a great positive impact
on people coming in and
we have record low numbers of people
coming in illegally that's helped
greatly
it was really meant for a different
purpose but it worked out very well for
what we're doing right now and for the
pandemic
nationwide beyond the outbreak in
several states cases remain
low and very stable 19 states have
positive test rates of less than five
percent eight states have positive test
rates of
less than two percent our nationwide
positive test rate is beginning to
decline and is currently at 8.8 percent
compared to over 16 percent at its peak
in april
it's coming down it's coming down fairly
rapidly today
we surpassed first time we surpassed 50
million tests that's far more than any
country in the world
india is second we believe
we think if 1.4 billion people
that's about 12 million tests we have 50
million tests
we're working with every state to
ensure the supply of rem deserver
for early case intervention and steroid
treatment and various other treatments
for those that are seriously ill we're
working very closely with
hospitals doctors nursing homes
everybody
the rem december has proven to be uh
terrific our case fatality rate
continues to decline and we want to push
this
rate even lower the therapeutic research
continues daily
or new and very promising treatments
including antibody treatments and
the use of blood thinners and steroids a
lot of different things are
happening and a lot of things are coming
out that
we wouldn't have known number of months
ago we're doing tremendously well on
therapeutic research and tremendously
well on the vaccines and frankly
therapeutically or maybe a word even
beyond that word is cure would be the
best of all and we'll see what happens
but uh
that would be great if we could go into
the hospital and just cure people
and we're at a position we're actually
able to
to a certain extent with what we have
right now and we think
in a very short period of time we'll be
able to do that our strategy is to
shelter the highest risk americans
while allowing younger and healthier
citizens to return to work or school
while being careful
and very vigilant wear a mask socially
distance and repeatedly wash your hands
practice very very good sanitary
means you have to do this you have to
just you have to look at it differently
wash your hands often
i'm finding more and more people are
saying wash your hands so
wash your hands we want young americans
to avoid packed bars and
other crowded indoor gatherings and
we're all in this together
and as americans we're going to
get this complete we're going to do it
properly we've been doing it properly
sections of the country come up that we
didn't anticipate for instance
florida texas etc but we're
working with very talented people very
brilliant people
and it's all going to work out and it is
working out
so with that i'll take a few questions
please yeah please mr president i just
want to ask you a question about the
surge of federal agents to various
cities
yeah the mayor of chicago just said
moments ago that you're doing this to
divert attention from your failures on
coronavirus
you are only targeting you haven't had
that failure you are only targeting
cities
run by democrats is this just a
political stash
yeah the cities unfortunately that are
in trouble are all run by democrats you
have
radical left democrats running cities
like chicago and so many others that we
just had a news conference and
uh unfortunately that's the way it is i
mean that's the
facts when you look at chicago and you
look at the job
mayor lightfoot sent me a letter
yesterday and
i think in their own way they want us to
go in there'll be a time when they're
going to want us to go in full blast but
right now we're sending extra people to
help
we're arresting a lot of people that
have been very bad
as far as the coronavirus as you say uh
i think we've done some amazing things
and i think you'll probably see that
if you compare our statistics to other
countries and
uh if you look at death rates etc you're
going to see and especially into the
future with what's happening you're
going to see some very very
impressive numbers for the united states
john please
mr president do you plan to do a
national strategy to help
schools reopen and reopen safely and
regarding
the children in your family your son
your grandchildren
are you comfortable do you plan to have
them back in person
in school yeah i am comfortable with
that and we do have a national strategy
but as you know ultimately it's up to
the governors of the states
i think most governors many governors
want the schools
open i would like to see the schools
open especially when you see
statistics like this we have great
statistics and on young people
and on safety so we would like to see
schools open
we want to see the economy open we just
had a report literally as i walked in
that we set an all-time record on
housing price increases uh up i think
they said 21 percent
which is a record that's never happened
before that's a great sign we have a
an economy that's going to be booming
it's going to be a lot of jobs are being
produced the job numbers will be coming
out shortly
meaning over the next week or so and i
think it'll be a continuation of the
last two months the last two months have
been
incredible uh so i think we're gonna
have a great economy you're gonna have a
fantastic next year i think you're gonna
have a very good third quarter actually
when the third quarter numbers come out
interestingly they'll be announced just
before the election they'll be announced
around november 1st so uh yeah
i would like to see the schools open
open a hundred percent
and we'll do it safely we'll do it
carefully but when you look at the
statistics i just read having to do with
children and
and safety uh they're very impressive
they have very strong immune systems
but you would understand that the
children who go to school then
go back to home they're with some live
with their grandparents
there's a real risk would you understand
themselves they do say that
they don't transmit very easily and a
lot of people are saying they don't
transmit and we're looking at that we're
studying john very hard
that particular subject that they don't
bring it home with them now they don't
catch it easily they don't bring it home
easily and if they do catch it they get
better fast we're looking at that fact
that is a factor and we're looking at
that very strongly we'll be reporting
about that over the next week please
mr president uh at least three uh
governors today
came out with new orders on mass
requirements
is that something you wish all the
governors would do
well a lot of the governors they have
different
requirements some of the governors are
very strong in mass
others aren't i think it's really going
to ultimately be up to them we've given
them the facts we've given them
everything we know they have their own
facts
some are strong in masks and as you know
some aren't in the same
ballpark but i think well i think all
are suggesting if you want to wear a
mask you
wear it i bring one i have one i've worn
it
and i think when i'm in certain settings
like hospitals and various
or when i'm close when you know when you
can't socially distance
i believe in it let's see do i
have it and if if you know in certain in
certain instances i think you really
uh i think you want to travel with a
mass there are instances where you
really
can use it i i would believe it would be
a good thing yeah
d.c mayor bowser came up with such an
order today
it of course doesn't apply to federal
properties but would you encourage
uh federal properties and including the
white house complex to
follow the order we're gonna we're gonna
make a decision over the next uh
24 hours we'll let you know what that
decision is okay thank you thank you
please
president trump do you agree with senate
republicans discussing the possibility
of
extending short-term unemployment
insurance today
um so that uh they prevent benefits from
expiring
well i think a lot of uh politicians are
discussing that republicans democrats
and
right now a lot of my representatives
are on the hill they're discussing
uh cares act or phase four whatever you
want to call it
and i think ultimately something good
will come out of it
the economy is starting to really come
back strongly when you look at the
numbers even
with the fact that like california is
still closed up in many big states
i think the numbers are even more
impressive considering that some states
like california big ones
are pretty well shut down so uh
we expect to have something over a
period of time over the appropriate
period of time
thank you very much these two questions
are with uh andrew feinberg and jc buick
one is today he said you're sending
federal law enforcement
officers to run cities run by extreme
politicians that's the word you used
which who happen to be all democrats who
supported black lives matter
protests american industries
no i said democrat politicians and
these are the cities where you have the
problem if you look at
chicago if you look at detroit if you
look i mean look around any of these
cities where we have the problems
and we're sending them help but we're
really waiting for them to call for the
big help for the big numbers for the
large numbers of people that we have
ready
willing and able you look at chicago
where 14 people were
shot yesterday where over the weekend
many people died and many people were
shot and over the last month they're
setting record numbers
we are waiting for the mayor
respectfully and other mayors
and governors to call us we are ready
willing and able to go in there with
great force
now we also have people that are going
in and arresting
drug dealers arresting some of the
shooters that are doing the shooting we
know who they are
we're working with police forces and
even though in some cases they're told
don't work with the federal government
the police forces
have great respect for the federal
government what we do
but we're ready willing and able to go
into these cities that are just being
decimated with
shooting and we're going to help please
i have a question on crime but first
i don't think we really got an
explanation yesterday on why the health
experts are no longer joining you at
these briefings can
can you explain why because they're
briefing me i'm meeting them i just
spoke to dr
fauci uh dr burks is right outside
and they're giving me all of uh
everything they know as of uh
as of this point in time and i'm giving
the information to you and i think it's
probably
a very uh concise way of doing it it
seems to be working out very well
okay so they're very much they're very
much involved they're very much
the relationships are all very good all
very good the relationships that we have
with the doctors
with everybody working on the virus has
been i think
extraordinary kaylie's here and i think
you would say the same thing you work
with them all the time yeah go ahead
in 2016 you said it was president
obama's fault that homicides were up in
chicago
so why was it the president's fault then
but it's not your fault
now chicago is a disaster
the mayor is saying don't come in the
mayor is telling us not to come in
at some point we can avoid that if we
have to but we and we may have to at
some because it's out of control
i assume she's saying that for political
reasons i think it's negative political
reasons she's a
uh she's a democrat i'm going to be nice
she's a democrat
she's making a big mistake people are
dying in chicago and other cities
and we can solve the problem they have
to ask us but we can solve the problem
president obama's fault in 2016. you
credited it as
president obama was invited in and he
did a poor job
president obama could have gone into
chicago he could have solved the problem
and he didn't in our case they don't
want us in
we can solve the problem very easily
we're equipped with the best equipment
the best people
and you see what we're doing i mean
portland was coming down it was
busting at the seams and we went in and
protected all the federal buildings
those
federal buildings are totally protected
but and we had to do that and portland's
a very different place in chicago
but chicago should be calling us and so
should philadelphia and detroit and
others
to go in and really help them because
when you're losing many people a weekend
many many people you see the same
numbers as i do when you're losing these
people
they should call us and they should say
come on in and
it's incredible to me but they're not
doing it at some point they will at some
point we may have no other choice but to
go in
uh jeff please mr president are you
looking at closing further chinese
embassies in the united states
and did you ask ambassador woody johnson
to bring the british open to your
thornberry
or turnberry property in scotland no i
never spoke to woody johnson about that
about turnberry turnberry is a
highly respected course as you know one
of the best in the world and
uh i read i read a story about it today
and i had never i never spoke to woody
johnson about doing that no
uh as far as closing additional
embassies it's always possible you see
what's going on we thought there was a
fire
in the one that we did close and
everybody said there's a fire there's a
fire and i guess they were burning
documents or burning
papers and i wonder what that's all
about okay how about one or two more
please
thank you would you like to respond to
joe biden who today
described you you might have heard that
as the first racist
to be elected president that those are
his that was his words
well you know it's interesting because
we did criminal justice reform
we passed criminal justice reform
something that obama
and biden were unable to do we did
opportunity cities we did the greatest
if you look at what we've done with
opportunity zones
nobody's ever even thought of a plan
like that uh
prior to the china plague coming in
floating in coming into our country and
really uh
doing terrible things all over the world
doing terrible things
we had the best african-american
hispanic-american
asian-american almost every group was
the best for
unemployment the unemployment numbers
were the best uh
you look at so you look at employment
you look at opportunity zones
and maybe most importantly when you look
at criminal justice reform
you look at prison reform i've done
things that nobody else and i've said
this and i say it openly and not a lot
of people
dispute it i've done more for black
americans
than anybody with the possible exception
of abraham lincoln nobody has even been
close
thank you very much everybody
you